we were talking about that like i
watched uh river runner [ __ ] dude uh
the only reason i watched it was like
these ki these white water rafters same
thing as the climbers right people die
all the time guys oh four of my friends
drown
okay well that's fine um and he was all
bunched up about it they're all i get it
that you're bunched up there it is
meanwhile they go down the [ __ ] they
go down beyond paddling wait where'd
they go they're in water they go it's
white water rafting they go in africa
things get dicey so don't see how small
that is yeah they go in africa down
these insane rapids some of the worst in
the world
and then when you land in the still
water
it is the area of crocodiles well there
are more crocodiles than hippos than
anywhere else
so why the world
anywhere else go look at this little
sardine go to the go to the trailer and
let me show it's just go to the trailer
and take a look at what i'm saying i'll
tell you with stuff like like the guy
climbing all the mountains the river
thing yeah all i need to see is the
trailer look at me to the right look at
that
dude watch him watch please watch look
at that boy he's watching him get it man
get out of here you got to start from
somewhere where did you start his dog 11
million views but watch watch um look at
him do me a favor and watch this and
tell me how this makes sense
like
you [ __ ] up
just the white one but let's add
crocodiles and like i don't understand
why standing on top of a rabbit
you still know that even though you've
done all of this that is insane to me
that one moment well people die all the
time
yeah
like all the time
and you don't see that
that's part of what it look at that guy
did you say
[Music]
couldn't figure out one of those levels
forever those teeth are cool they have
an inner fire why is everyone so well so
as their friends apparently apparently
one of the things you got to be to be a
kayaker's ugly something well guy
kaiken's been [ __ ] tough on him
moment that's his girl
his mom explained to kayaking
physically healing yeah i was mentally
[ __ ] up meditating white
to get me back oh why
polish
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] kidding hard pass
you you watch this hard yeah that's not
the one i wanted you oh god don't make
me watch another one that's it quick
that's it
that's the trailer bro that's it i can't
believe you said wow this is
that was the trailer bro from netflix no
i just want you to see that looks good i
want you to see where it's like two
seconds where do they show the crocs go
just find the wall just keep going down
is this the 58 second one right here
yeah it's probably the shortest [ __ ]
one
it's the short one
just tell me which one i'll just do
oh god talk amongst yourselves talk
amongst yourselves talk amongst
yourselves
my name is crystal wiles i don't know if
this was
this
no [ __ ] this one [ __ ] this go back to
the other one go back to the other go
there where's that one
crocodiles i don't know let's see this
one oh wait hold on hey do you think you
made that up no
because you don't think they're throwing
crocodiles and hippos in the first
trailer
wait
if we're gonna do this we gotta be all
in are you [ __ ] kidding me
no that's the same trailer but cut
anyways yeah they go in africa and no
they don't where they're still not he's
in india bro huh yeah this is this one
talks about him doing four rivers in
india
no i know bubba but they they did a
thing where they're like if you fall
over
if you fall over you're in some you're
in some real do you think they're making
that up for the cameras they're
officially the river runner crocodiles
i don't see any kayak or necks or
crocodiles oh man they go into those
waters with these [ __ ] things they
died that would have been on the trailer
it is on the trailer
we just watched it
it's chin's fault he could never find it
which of your president most croc no no
don't worry about that i'm just trying
to find out there's a [ __ ] that one
the official trailer is the one
which river has the one that we just
watched from just that one is that the
moment
again let's watch it again
let's watch it these these [ __ ] you
like that stuff yeah climbing mountains
going down wait did you watch that dock
yeah you watched that the minute i saw
the crocodiles i had to watch that part
i was like you get in the water
crocodiles my biggest fear yeah and and
and do you think they got into it hippos
do you think they actually rode with
crocodiles do you think i see them in
that water
but did you see the man
crocodile that's not true yes nope they
showed crocodile you know what it is
like naked afraid where they're like
this land is lions and crocodiles and
you know what happens i'm making afraid
no one ever runs into a crocodiles or
lions and that's what happened here they
showed up you see him like this just get
footage and you see this huge crocodile
like no yeah like what the [ __ ] no
they're like i'm sure they're like
they're
we've seen crocodiles in this river
before find it try my best
and it shows a little crocodile eyes up
out of the water no they're you like
you've never seen everywhere they're
[ __ ] everywhere they're never close
to those animals never oh
i can't believe this [ __ ] there's all
one thing about kayaking when we get
done we get [ __ ] up
all right oh by the way
though so anybody who does that the
extremists like that the guys who climb
the mountains and stuff and they drink a
beer up there well that's that's called
an addictive personality so they almost
always have a history of drinking
substance abuse there's they're they
won't do one type of acid they do all
the acid don't they get don't you get
like drunk like easier when you go up
that that high what's that
that elevation well they're not high are
they they're they're at sea level no i
thought you were talking about the uh
hikers
yeah i guess you smoke weed on top of
everest you get pretty [ __ ] high this
is uh this is not your guy
what is this there it is i told you
they're
they're getting attacked by a crocodile
uh nobody's gonna attack that's actually
scary yeah you see what they're doing
now so dum-dums so you guys are on your
kayaks and you're wondering why now
though oh [ __ ] oh
that looks crazy get that close but
while they're coming after them is what
they're doing kind of sorry it's okay
well that's all good dude nice oh [ __ ]
that was a big cut oh [ __ ]
that's it
little boat in costa rica and i was all
up on that crop you were giving it a
little pet oh yeah you let your fingers
drag across it really hanging off
he was the size of this room yeah it was
a diamond it was a dinosaur yeah hanging
like that 20 it was they called him
osama bin laden 23 feet long he's so big
he was just like
he lets his hand just go
and i was like dude that thing can turn
around he looked tired though he's just
laughing
they feed him yeah yeah oh if he decided
we'd be drive and roll yeah a little
shitty boat too no you got to get your
legs around his body and just go with it
you roll with them is that what you do
there's that woman who did that with the
alligator she got oh yeah
yeah we watched on here yeah